Mount Athos a place where time has stood
still preserving an ancient simple and
pious way of life a collection of
engravings now on display in the
European Parliament gives us a glimpse
into the cultural riches and austere
traditions of the monks that inhabit the
holy mountain women and children are
banned from the settlement which houses
20 monasteries and has a special
political status allowing it to opt out
of some of the EU single market rules
Doris offers Danica me assessing the
brexit que me to politically anaemia
parado she made CBA the rocky testes
been in the mono 350 course you make a
Testament in story Sofia and then post
at the port and many v8 protesters
Dwight you're a tourist office mm I
didn't wanna Dakota the pieces are in
Brussels for a millennium celebration of
Russian monastic life on the peninsula
and to mark 2016 as a special year of
culture for Greece and Russia
what's the erotic tour i onerous yes or
nifty polity anunnaki morons Selina
select jamie anneka minakata who then
very or is adam honest an APC machine or
Otto a little cradle nestled in Greece's
rugged northern coastline
man Davos has been the spiritual home of
the Christian Orthodox Church for over a
thousand years